[Musica]
da sempre l'architettura è stata una
necessità primaria dell'uomo
abbiamo sempre cercato di usare al
meglio la natura per difenderci dalla
stessa natura creando delle capanne
creando delle grotte dei rifugi che ci
potessero proteggere per me
l'architettura è davvero un atto
straordinario perché unisce quella parte
molto concreta molto reale ma con la
creatività ed è proprio lì che comincia
davvero il mio il mio viaggio come la
prima pelle naturale ovviamente
l'epidermide protegge i nostri organi
protegge tutto quello che ci fa stare in
piedi e vivere la seconda è l'abito e
tutti avrete sicuramente provato qual è
la differenza tra indossare un capo di
cashmere di lana comunque di fibre
naturali rispetto a quello a cui
purtroppo sempre di più oggi siamo
abituati che quello invece di indossare
capi di fibre sintetiche che ci fanno
sudare e che di sicuro non ci fanno
stare benissimo
e così per me la casa è davvero una
terza pelle una pelle che protegge
l'uomo da gli agenti atmosferici
principalmente e dove passiamo più del
98 per cento del nostro tempo perché
siamo all'interno di un teatro perché
siamo all'interno di una casa una scuola
di un ufficio di tutti quegli spazi che
ci servono per poter fare la nostra
attività quasi quotidiana quando non
siamo all'esterno sempre di più
oggi siamo spinti da una modernità ed
alla ricerca di un edificio che
apparentemente crediamo essere il meglio
gli skyline di new york di milano di
dubai
questi grattacieli in vetro e acciaio
che sono veramente energivori ci fanno
male e ci fanno ammalare perché da soli
sono la terza causa dell'inquinamento e
dei cambiamenti climatici consumano
nella sola fase di costruzione non
soltanto l'energia il 36 per cento di
tutta l'energia ma sono la causa del 40
per cento delle emissioni della co2 di
un terzo di tutti i rifiuti del 50 per
cento delle materie prime vergini e il
17 per cento dell'acqua potabile sono
edifici energivori che non possono più
essere il nostro stile di vita
il nostro obiettivo io assolutamente non
volevo fare l'architetto se questo era
quello che
dovevo costruire così ho lasciato milano
perché cercavo la possibilità di
costruire delle case davvero sane e
belle pulite e
e giuste mi sono ritrovata in in questo
paesaggio un paesaggio davvero
particolare e poi forse tutto era già
scritto nel mio cognome mi sono trovata
davvero a vivere tra i monti e il riso e
questo è il paesaggio che mi ha accolto
quando sono arrivata a biella dove un
paesaggio straordinario io sono nato e
cresciuto al ecco quindi niente di così
diverso ma la brianza è molto costruita
e la natura si percepisce davvero poco e
un po a lato della quotidianità ma qui
invece sei dentro la natura perché il
paesaggio della risaia cambia ogni tre
mesi cambiano i colori cambiano gli
odori prima e marrone poi diventa un mar
a quadretti poi verde come fosse un
prato all'inglese fino a diventare
giallo quando il riso e finalmente
maturo e potrà essere tagliato
ed è proprio nel riso che è cominciata
tutta la mia ricerca il riso viene
prodotto in
in tutti i cinque continenti in più di
120 paesi al mondo e l'italia e il
produttore di riso in europa
biella il paese dove più a nord del
mondo viene prodotto il riso ma riso non
è soltanto nutrimento che la parte più
importante perché sfama quasi il 60 per
cento dell'intera popolazione mondiale
ma il riso e anche sviluppo del
territorio e via diversità e cultura e
storia
l'italia produce 150 varietà di risi
diversi e tantissime ricette che
sicuramente conoscerete ma in questi
anni
l'aver unito in qualche modo
l'agricoltura all'architettura due mondi
veramente lontani che non si sono mai
parlati mi ha fatto scoprire invece che
l'agricoltura è piena di spunti e di
risorse perché tutto quello che non è
nutrimento c'è tutto quello che non è il
chicco di riso che arriva sulle nostre
tavole
per me diventa non più uno scarto non lo
vedo come uno scarto lo vedo veramente
come un'eccellenza come una nuova
materia prima rinnovabile rinnovabile
ogni anno perché ogni anno tra settembre
e ottobre il riso viene tagliato 7
tonnellate ogni ettaro diventano
nutrimento ma 10 tonnellate ogni ettaro
sono scarti sono lolla questa la pelle
del chicco la prima protezione che viene
che viene tolta quando il riso dal campo
viene tagliato e viene portato alla
riseria per essere lavorato per essere
trasformato in maniera assolutamente
meccanica e non chimica diventa riso
integrale e quindi troviamo la lolla
diventa riso bianco e troviamo la pula
ma nel campo resta la paglia la paglia
di riso non viene utilizzata per gli
animali
non ha nessun nessun uso perché contiene
tantissima silice che chimicamente
per quanto riguarda l'architettura
diventa una caratteristica tecnica
veramente interessante perché perché gli
permette di non marcire che è proprio
quello che serve alle nostre case se
deve utilizzarlo come materiale di
costruzione deve essere durabile ed ecco
perché siccome non c'è realmente un uso
e un commercio viene principalmente
bruciata
oggi la regione piemonte la regione
lombardia dove si produce diciamo il 93
per cento del riso italiano l'abitato
agitato la bruciatura in campo ma
l'italia lo produce anche in veneto in
sicilia in calabria sono piccole realtà
ma con grandi biodiversità e con grande
qualità per me tutti questi materiali
sono diventati davvero una materia prima
una materia prima che mi permette di
produrre materiali edili dagli scarti
del riso e costruire delle case delle
case sane e belle pulite
per quanto riguarda l'ambiente e giuste
per quanto riguarda l'uomo ovviamente
tutti starete pensando alla favola dei
tre porcellini col quale inevitabilmente
siamo cresciuti dove il lupo in un
soffio spazzava via proprio la casa di
paglia era la prima ad essere eliminata
è solo quella i mattoni riusciva a
resistere al lupo e quindi riusciva a
proteggere l'uomo e il tempo invece io
vi dimostro come la paglia può essere
davvero un materiale
meraviglioso per costruire case case
sane case che resistono nel tempo
questa è la casa più antica che esiste
un'europa si trova a montare scissa
appena fuori parigi e del 1923 e
perfettamente in uso oggi gli arredi
l'anno donata alla un'associazione di
architetti che si occupa proprio di
divulgare le tecniche e la possibilità
di costruire con materiali come la
paglia ma li troviamo in tutta in tutta
europa in tutto il mondo sono case sane
questa si trova in in austria e una
ristrutturazione sotto questa nuova
pelle che è un cappotto proprio come
quello che ci mettiamo di inverno
c'è una casa degli anni 70 che è stata
completamente riqualificata non solo a
livello estetico ma anche e soprattutto
a livello energetico perché la casa non
ha più bisogno del riscaldamento non ha
più bisogno del condizionatore in estate
non è più energivora ma anzi riduce
tutto ciò che avviene in produzione
perché consuma meno acqua consuma meno
co2 e diventa veramente una casa
autosufficiente questo è un progetto in
croazia ma li troviamo in italia a
chamois quest e propone edificio da me
progettato ovviamente non sono tutti i
miei progetti ma sempre di più ci sono
progettisti che si approcciano questo
tipo di materiale per poter realizzare
architetture sane e si trova a chamois
1800 metri non ha riscaldamento non ha
il condizionatore
ma a vicenza ma un social housing a
parigi un teatro a tallinn un albergo in
francia a nax una un ufficio di
un'azienda automobilistica in svizzera a
milano un temporary office su un tetto
di un edificio industriale un'università
in in inghilterra in una scuola in
francia sono davvero tantissimi
ovviamente vi starete chiedendo dove io
abito io abito qui in una casa di riso
che ho recuperato perché solo
sperimentando su di me per primo potevo
capire se veramente quello che stava
facendo
che stavo facendo aveva un senso e
potevo davvero proporlo a tutti gli
altri sono case sani e apparentemente
davvero simili a quelle in cui tutti
viventi tutti i giorni ma oggi dobbiamo
fare davvero un passo avanti dobbiamo
cambiare la nostra prospettiva uscire da
quel mondo dell'economia lineare che
negli ultimi cinque anni
negli ultimi 50 anni ha davvero
utilizzato e sfruttato il più possibile
le risorse ma purtroppo le risorse ci
siamo resi conto che la terra con una
navicella spaziale le risorse fisiche
sono finite sono finite nel senso che
non le possiamo continuare ad utilizzare
all'infinito ma abbiamo l'obbligo di
capire come utilizzarle come utilizzarle
al meglio dobbiamo tutti renderci più
consapevoli e capire come vi ricordate
sicuramente questo film che è the truman
show dove il suo mondo era finito ma lui
non lo sapeva
l'ha capito soltanto alla fine quando è
arrivato a sbattere contro la fine del
suo mondo che era un mondo finito che
era stato costruito esclusivamente per
lui ma lui aveva una via d'uscita poteva
salire quella scala e uscire da quella
porta
noi dobbiamo trovare la nostra via
d'uscita una via d'uscita da un'economia
lineare che passa a un'economia
circolare dove parte dal mondo della
natura sfrutta le sue risorse al meglio
per costruire oggetti architettura
design moda dagli scarti del riso si può
davvero fare tutto ma dove l'elemento
principale che l'agricoltura produce
nutrimento tutto il resto lo possiamo
fare semplicemente coi suoi scarti e
quando gli oggetti non ci serviranno più
quando la casa verrà ristrutturata la
potremo far tornare alla terra tutti
quei materiali non saranno da rifiuti
speciali non andranno ad aumentare a
riempire le nostre discariche che ormai
stanno esplodendo torneranno alla natura
sotto forma di fertilizzante perché i
materiali da noi prodotti sono
completamente naturali non usano chimica
perché possono stare insieme con
deleganti naturali che la natura ci
offre e alla fine torneranno alla natura
stessa torneranno a quel campo di a quel
campo di riso che gli permetterà di ri
continuare il suo ciclo
quindi dobbiamo trovare questa via
d'uscita
finita ma non per salvare la terra
perché a volte oggi ci sempre di più ci
continuano a dire che dobbiamo salvare
la terra
no dobbiamo salvare l'uomo noi siamo
soltanto passeggeri su questa terra e
dobbiamo capire che quando ci alziamo
dal nostro posto se stiamo viaggiando in
treno in aereo
dobbiamo lasciare il nostro posto pulito
per il passeggero che verrà dopo di noi
ecco la stessa cosa la dobbiamo fare
nella nostra vita quotidiana
dobbiamo trovare quella via d'uscita che
ci permette davvero di essere passeggeri
di salvare l'uomo che ha un'esistenza
temporanea ma che i suoi stili di vita
hanno delle conseguenze davvero
permanenti troviamo la nostra via
d'uscita e come le materie abbiamo
capito che sono fisiche e quindi
limitate ma noi abbiamo a disposizione
una grande materia illimitata che la
nostra intelligenza
quindi unendo i dati scientifici
scientifici e la nostra intelligenza
possiamo creare davvero degli scenari
futuri degli scenari che ci permettono
di salvare l'uomo di salvare l'esistenza
della nostra specie umana che sarà
permanente ma senza lasciare delle
conseguenze per le generazioni future
senza causare dei danni che loro non
sapranno più come uscire perché saranno
irreversibili
io ho visto davvero una casa nella
risaia e voi voi cosa ci vedete
grazie mille
[Applauso]